what's the worst time you've choked a
game
over the board
i had the hiccups once during a chess
tournament
but that's not really comparable to
choking anyway let's play bullets
playing fm kimster wait it's
i i thought it's oh berserk i guess
i thought this was one minute chess
hurrah finally caught you've read handed
her
streaming oh yeah
but my hands are
are not red i guess they're tan
i was playing tennis the other day i
play a4 here
ac6 some idea of eventual b5
yeah i'm getting b5
like playing very quickly
um
i'm getting squeezed a little bit but at
least my my pieces are finding squares
kind of i'll put the knight on f8 and
then
um
yeah it's not pleasant let's go for
upbeat hail oh is that toilet
oh no it's not toilets i was expecting
the toilet noggin
toilet always says that okay i have to
focus
a first game um
and it's really uncomfortable
but thanks everyone thanks for the hell
bits there's hari krishnan
let's develop the queen attack the pawn
[Music]
like c7 what else to do
oh g5 that's a strong g5
i'll double up
oh i have bishop a6id oh can't do it
oh good job i'm still confused
all right let's bring the bishop
somewhere
[Music]
okay let's try and trade
to play that move not a happy move
confusing
i tried i was close
i just didn't have enough time okay
nothing to get too disappointed about
only in the first game
it's a three hour long tournament oh i
thought okay
i i got i i i made too many false
assumptions
so i thought it was a two hour long
bullet tournament
but it's a three hour long three hour
long blitz tournaments
wow so it's 3-0 okay
it's like i can pace myself
that last game got my my heart racing
but um
okay let's play blitz i'll try and
manage my time
as uh as decently as possible
does this move i have f6 and bishop g4
i can always play king h8 after after
bishop c4
what to play here for some idea of queen
d5
i think i'll move the bishop to f7
i don't mind this the structure is a bit
more pleasant for black
queen d7 rook e8
oh vlad is here what's up vlad and hello
to
yeah hello to everyone else um oh
someone gifted a sub
a naru ramar gifting a sub to picazzo
thanks so much
hmm
[Music]
yeah this is only open file so i think
it makes sense to
to double up
it is nice having having more time in
this game
time to think time to minimize blunders
this pawn's a bit loose
yeah let's just play queen c8
don't uh exploit the the commands
i think the previous stream there are
some people spamming commands that's
that's a time outable offense
um what to play though
it's a decent move probably knight c4
i'm liking the position pieces are
comfortable
let's play g6 hitting the bishop maybe
this move
i'm just looking for a plan here thanks
for subbing oh dynamic chess
gifting subs thanks so much dynamic
chess
people should check out dynamic chess on
twitch
of this move so if takes takes i
i fork hmm
b-pawn is slightly weak
okay i'm just going to take and trade i
think this is the simplest
expecting queen takes
and andrew just how's it going
oh knight takes you can still play this
i'm allowing this move
i'm also down a minute what
okay i have bishop d5
it doesn't quite work though like queen
e2
this is not good play yeah because
knight g5 is coming
yeah whatever that means
i i have to focus i
it feels like just a minute ago i was
like so thankful about having so much
time
and now i'm have almost no time
okay let's trade queens or rooks
that's a good move if h6
i'm just preventing knight g5
oh maybe preparing this and this
the queen trapped the queen's trapped oh
g5
let's get some g5 emotes just trapping
the queen
well i played g5 i didn't realize it's
actually trapping the queen
okay so i just win stuff here i'm going
to win the night if night moves out then
i promote
that's so nice
okay now i can thank people thanks hari
krishnan
for the mubarak goodbye bits
and g5 and rose and g5 and frozen g5
yeah yeah there's a g pawn soon to turn
into an s pawn
soon to become a queen my opponent is
rage stalling
and the chat is filled with g5 emotes
and thank you
oh thanks diamond cutter giving a shout
out to that dynamic chess
dynamic chess you should play the
tournament your title player
whoa and it's flags with 1500 bits
thanks so much it's a nice way to
oh opponent finally resigned okay um so
i'm on the
i'm on the scoreboard i broke into the
top 300.
yeah thanks double the pawns i
appreciate it
and oh and thank you nando's chuck nod
chuck nhd for summon and
nord dirto also subbing oh i'm playing
i think this is a decently strong gm
g5 it's jay the tiger okay so i'm
playing a stafford gambit against a gm
oh he knows what to do
oh i think this is a move first fighting
queen h4
and then some kind of f5
i'll start with bishop d6
almost almost no one plays this uh this
line
okay this wait did white go wrong
already
he may have gone wrong because bishop f5
was threatening queen h4
a king d1 now i have this move
oh it's getting spicy and this is what i
want
i also have this move wait if i play
that there's queenie one
i'm wishing i've i studied this line at
some point
um
[Music]
yeah i can't quite get away with
wow i could play g so g5 defends my
queen and threatens knight g3
and i don't know how white stops it
i might be trapping my own queen with g5
so the idea is to play this and after
this i can safely take because
the queen's defended so g5 again let's
get some g5 emotes i don't know how good
this is though
i'm also securing f4 for the knight
maybe
but i'm trying to meet d4 with knight g3
oh oh that was simple from white
as it just escaped my mind i have to
play h6
at least we still have a weird position
i have to move quicker let's castle
bishop e3 coming
i'm still playable f5 coming this bishop
oh so many g5s oh i i had scrolled up in
the chat i was wondering why it was so
slow
because i was okay i have to focus on
the chest not the chat
wait a2 free pawn probably not a free
pawn
let's just align with everything
the pieces that i have left are are
decently placed
except my queen
if i take
yeah let's um let's run away
maybe this move next just want to attack
a2
i really have to work on my my time
management oh it's toggy what's up
talking
oh maybe that's why i was supposed to
look at the chat
all right opponent taking a long time
that's that's nice
i feel like time is going to be my
savior maybe
oh yeah fridge noise i i know i can't
have to keep my food cold
so if takes can i take on d3
probably not i want to though
let's just take here play simple chess
knight e4 i have g4
that's a bold move
[Music]
um
so i'm threatening oh maybe i'm not
threatening that
maybe the plan is just this and then i
mean the knight could be pinned
it's already pinned
bishop f4 is a good move
yeah let's go for the the d file double
up
maybe a5
i always play king b8
[Music]
i'm gonna need a miracle here
aligning with the king
that was a nasty move
yeah no stalemate ideas unless
that was close any other oh no
never mind yeah my opponent now played
me in that game
um the opening was interesting though
g5 was probably not a good move
i'm wondering if i was if i have time
later
maybe right now oops let me just check
was like better after king d1
ah so i'm gonna have four
queenie one makes sense oh bishop f2
oh that's a cool line and if queen c4
queen f2 wow d4
bishop d6 oh defending the knight and e5
okay i'm i'm learning something if i
play the same player again i'll i'll try
and go into the same line
oh playing casablanca um who's also
streaming
people can watch both of our our
commentary let's play a london
i don't remember playing him so many
times but i guess i have
so we have some kind of london main line
yeah with this queen c7 variation i
uh i enjoy taking early
and then
you're trying to remember if it's i
think it's e4 immediately
there's some idea that pawn takes bishop
takes
well it's better to um
to keep the knights
i'm also threatening e5 here
so in this case i think it's better to
take with knight
now actually i think bishop is is a bit
more venomous
i remember looking at this i had this in
the um the may
the may tournament that ben ran uh in
the final round
it's on youtube in very similar position
where i i castle queenside and then i
went for like the kingside attack
and somehow it fizzled um
i wonder if i can play g5 here or um g4
here
and there's knight takes i need a good
reason for it
i have this move too
95 i could be losing a pawn i could be
losing f2
um but that's part of life
if i lose f2 i have rook f1 and then i
um when f7 really
so i'm winning f7 here i think
i could lose g3 but
oh wait f7 is f7 hanging
maybe this rook f1 here and then
knight takes it's interesting
a little bit of time to think there's
also this move
um
oh he's just gonna go back to b6 though
there's also g4
all so many moves maybe just g4
yeah i can black options here
it's a bit hard to develop the stuff
h5 idea g5
and then maybe mating eventually
oh that's a very tricky move if i take
those queen g5
i can play g5 first goodbye tagi
this move just simple chess
i want to play rook h1
king g7 okay
i always play king b1
king g7 i'm trying to figure out if i
played knight f3
i probably just take though
good luck gary and then g5 the next
viewer swiss tournament
uh to be determined if you keep asking
though
it'll be likely sooner rather than later
let's play this move
so material wise black is fine but
black's very underdeveloped
and it seems like there is
where's my wind
seems like there's a lot of potential in
this position
so i'm threatening knight c4 and then
knight t6
also threatening this probably
there's no rook a6 because uh looks tied
down
[Music]
my time my beautiful time
oh let's take that
if takes live g4
i'm so sorry i mean it was it was just a
dirty time scramble
okay i think it draws i guess a fair
result
i feel like i was very close to winning
also very close to losing
um oh thanks don't cry so much subbing
for three months i feel like i probably
missed
a bit of what happened in the chat oh
hari krishnan
maybe communicating hey let's go zurich
and let's play d4 also drew skis thanks
for subbing
okay let's play fast let's try and stay
up on time
at least one game
okay don't mind the structure
really don't mind the structure iqp
position is very pleasant
i'll put the rook on on d1
yeah so this pawn is just an eternal
weakness
take queen d4 probably double up
i could win the pawn right away but i'm
trying torture black
just a little bit
okay here probably let's just take
we could also take here if black wins f2
i went f7 and then mate
i'll have to defend this
so the goal is to make a pass pawn
it should be a pretty routine win
queen c7 g3
just making sure silence
yeah oh yeah the the fridge stopped
making noises my queen defends us
i was just just winning
okay that's nice
so is carlson playing maybe chat would
know better than me
doctor thank you
maybe not oh thanks so much love
appreciate that
oh no carlson ah so my
my go live notification was maybe uh
clickbait
i said maybe carlson all right let's
play
it's not berserk let's play d4
i'll play london at some point i'll
probably switch to e4
but i do enjoy playing this this opening
whoa it's double pawns
thanks so much
so i think what's on line here
there's some idea of playing e5 at the
right moment
maybe right away
also taking
[Music]
let me take some 95
because of the pin
it could get sharp there's an e4 there's
not h5
it's not h5 i play this
threatening the bishop there's still a
pin even if takes takes
there's always a pin
and bishop g4 is a fine move
so we could trade it might just be
positional
let's trade
it's kind of a pawn sack white black
intake and then i have this move
so hitting this this and this now
there's knight d5
and queen d6
it feels like there should be something
here but i'm not seeing it
i guess just rookie one attack this
f6
like black black just seems so unstable
but i'm not seeing oh i guess i can take
on f6
yeah because queen takes home in the
night and i just have better structure
black has a c file but these pawns are
weak
probably going to win this pawn
oh magnus is online oh maybe he's gonna
late join i don't know
so i think he's played the last few
i don't think i've played a title arena
in a while
okay i missed the last one i just take
this
okay always happy for an end game
so i want my pawns on dark squares to
complement the bishop
hitting this
okay threatening to take
i'm dreaming of g5 mates
let's move first
g5 will be a fork
okay yeah the threat of g5 was uh was
strong enough
still worthy of g5 emotes
oh so maybe carlson late joined
interesting
i don't think i've ever played carlson
in blitz before
only only bullet so that's a new goal of
this tournament
probably shouldn't have deserved but
just want myself or
i want me i want i want to play quicker
i want to force myself to play quicker
knight b6 is the main line
otherwise rick d1
that's a new move
i haven't seen 95 before
not sure how strong it is
i'm threatening b4 too
yeah so i'm just winning the night
bishop d4
let's take
i'm probably just rook a2 here
it's still trapped if f5 i take
and then win the queen
if bishop f5
probably this move
black's going for counter punches i'm
just trying to simplify
and win the night
oh that's so tricky but i have this move
my knight on b1 was not defended this
knight's still trapped and the thing's
defended now
oh there's a line
where if i take take take i get forked
but i'll have two bishops for a rook
i also have this move
okay i'll go for this
yeah so this is much better for white
[Music]
still requires some technique
oh no oh no
this is really bad my bishop's getting
trapped
ah okay still gonna try and fight though
um
am i winning no not quite
ah that's very close
i i hung the bishop um but i still
fought
i was very close to mating here king
state's only move
magnus is destroying everyone in his
past
oh am i in his path
where is he doctor
oh i'm still above him in the tournament
though i have more points
i just have to keep pace
also leeches.org in the chat what's up
lee chess
all right let's um let's play
aggressively i won't beserk this game
play some grand prix setup
g6
this is some kind of line
and i'll admit i don't think i've looked
at this too
too closely
just e6
yeah we have kind of like a reverse
closed sicilian
97 i guess h5 is coming
let's play this and if knight t5 i have
queen f7
bishop here
wait what i just got forked i just got
four i could take on c3
ah i just got fourt that was really bad
that was such a simple oh i have this
move though
maybe it's not so bad
threatening made in two
and there's no b3 because night knight
is hanging
i guess there's queen b3
or that move okay let's not get forked
again
should probably just castle but now the
four coming
let's castle now that f4 queen f7
if i'm threatening this
or this
it's interesting upload the tournament
vod to youtube
i really like those long videos oh very
possibly
remind me remind me after the tournament
but you you can watch the long video in
real time
uh can i play i guess the pawns over
defended
i can still go for this
some kind of a4 idea
[Music]
um
i don't know what to do but i have to
play quickly
hey g5 let's get some wait what i win
back a piece
i win back a piece i'm still probably
worse
but oh it's not so bad
i'm only down a pawn white's king is on
f3
the question is what to do maybe fight
for the g file
because the the h rook is tied down to
h5
wondering if rook g4 works
i'll just go for this
yeah going for queen g2 oh i'm allowing
rip g1
which white misses
i'll just attack
queen c3 rook g7
oh that doesn't work though queen c3
rook g7 uh can take
takes takes so the same insane line
probably misses it that's probably also
a good move
that's actually a really that's probably
a better move
i have to take
and still down the pawn
do you think chess will ever be solved
like for example we know connect4 is
sold
um yeah at some point hasbro might buy
it
i already own scrabble
that was a blunder
okay it's getting interesting again i'm
gonna have a pass pawn
and light's a bit stuck
lights actually getting trapped
f5 i just played this
i think maybe
oh a5 was a bad move because now i win
the pawn
this is winning
how did i win this ending i was down
like three pawns
i was on three pawns right
i guess i was down two pawns but it was
tricky like the night got trapped
bishop saved the day let's go okay
so 10 points top 300
who's in first hmm
wow so people already have more than 30
points
yeah that was not a clean game i got
i got i guess i got forks in the opening
i just didn't see the pawn for that was
really bad
i have to be more tactically alert
oh i'm playing um ostrovsky
i actually don't know his rapper i think
he plays a sloth
pretty sure he's a sloth player
do i deserve i thought he would berserk
back
double pawns thanks for that
let's play this
okay berserking a higher rate player
thanks for that oh f6
yeah this is uh it's a fun line for
black
so the eventual idea is c4 which i
should have not played c3
that's a loss of a tempo
okay
and that will redevelop to e2 oh thanks
bombs
you the bomb and thanks skylake for the
clutch bits
distraction bits of love now now is not
the time for distraction bits
i don't know where the bishop should go
if i take let's just play solidly
bishop h6 i have bishop f4
not f1 to e3
e5 could be coming e5 is a bit of a
annoying move but maybe it's not so bad
the d5 is now a target and king will go
to d2
so
this thing
okay time isn't so bad anymore
attacking this thing now
oh good move you play this
my king is a bit misplaced
losing a pawn
i'm gonna try and make the most of it
so down upon rook ending
not so pleasant
so
i think he was winning there
wow so i i won i got the berserking
points
another dirty flag but uh held on there
rook ending down the pawn down on time
leetsku
oh thank you for subbing jazzy columnio
appreciate that so okay
trying to break into the top 200.
i'll play d4 just solid opening time
thanks for subbing ger
guerra crawley let's take and b5 bishop
b7 and c5
like 97 first
yeah i don't mind this looks pleasant
um now i really don't mind this
it's a skewer
so there's some idea of b4 i don't think
it's too damaging
b4927
wow what is this
so white's just going insane i think
i'll just play this
attack the bishop
i mean okay there's a lot of ways to win
this
um
maybe just some kind of like queen c5
or maybe rook c5
just going after the pawn
i wanted to play queen c5
i could play knight f8 and just be
be solid
i could play some um
i'll just play knight f8
oh interesting
this is all all okay
i mean white's definitely playing in
a reasonable style this i think just
wins
like when you're losing you want to try
and confuse your opponent
as much as possible uh but i'm not
getting mated
with queen f2 here
yeah and i have six i take knight always
defends h7
oh don't pre-move that i don't know what
i pre-moved
but okay it worked out oh playing paul
a strong player played this person on
unchest.com
hey jay thanks for the bits
oh yeah i think botez has a dirty flag
emote
but um
yeah that's it's a classic one
whoa it's odejak
gifting subs thanks so much
gifting two
to various people i think i should take
and play a3
just to close things down to marvel
lasso
spaka to duluz
nikhil 2501 local logos
and ran man what is this move
does that work i don't know if that
works
i'm up a piece oh knight of two
i'd have to wow
so black's either like losing instantly
or having some like brilliancy
and that h3 is also possible
so if i take there's knight c3 which is
interesting
which is knight h3
yeah i'll probably do that at some point
yeah i was talking with uh with levy the
other day might uh
do some collab seven swim thanks for
subbing
wait
oh knight f6
but this looks nice so i can take on
take on b3 and this move first
and eventually rook f1
like the knights always tie down to the
mating square
oh i'm allowing um playing this move
i was really uncalled for
black might actually win this
at this point though it's really oh wow
well played
it's not over though
if knight moves i have rook g6
that's a good move though
play this some idea of knight b3
i'm just down too many pawns
i'm down too many times too
[Music]
opponent was very tricky this game i'm
sure i was i was probably winning when i
won the piece
but it wasn't enough
i just resigned yeah
what should i do i miss queen to g2
i didn't see it soon enough saw when it
was too late
beautiful game though yeah lucky eric
yeah my opponent found some
some really clever moves
so i'm still oh i'm top 200.
um let's try and build up a streak again
oh i would have berserked back i didn't
have the chance though
trying to remember yeah let's take and
then this move
not sure if white can easily win back
the pawn
i will say it is very nice having the
time advantage
let's just trade everything
oh light one back the pawn i do have g6
bishop g8 i guess i should at least try
g6
some night before idea
this is win a piece i think it wins a
piece
both knights attacked
am i queening
not quite
i'll save the bishop first
um
i think this works
95 in the end
the knight and bishop had potential to
defend the h8 square
if i it doesn't quite work
so let's play this
looking for other moves
and this is good enough
knights are always tricky though
but so are pawns
oh okay this is still fine
or is it can take this
oh
yeah this is still winning
that was close it's like by one tempo
i was thinking it was that was one
possibility
um but the other line also panned out
all right gotta win
do you agree with hikaru that top level
tournaments will shift towards online
after covid
um not 100 but i think there will still
be
playing on my current correspondence
game
oh yeah yeah while in chorus finds chess
you have like all the time in the world
to see if like an end game wins by one
tempo
knight there's some kind of knight d7
idea
to prepare e5 and then getting knight b6
but yeah they're all like top level over
the board tournaments will definitely
exist
once uh once it becomes possible
um but her car was also saying that like
um basically rapid chess is the future
like rapid and blitz
i wouldn't be surprised if there will be
more like top level events like online
and
over the board in rapid blitz
so it can be more more spectator
friendly
and this is just like a reverse sicilian
king h8 my typical sicilian move
i'm going after the bishop white's
playing this well though
oh white's a grand master who is this
from cuba
i've heard of that name
have you played shogi i tried learning
once
i didn't get very far
actually it was um it was yuri shulman
grandmaster yuri shulman former us
champion
who who tried teaching me shogi
i know he played a bit
uh can i take
i don't know what's going on here in
this move
that structure is is a bit confusing
i think white's likely to take and then
play positionally
i mean with upon e4 i do want to attack
on the king side
and i say hey what's going on oh hey
leo stabile thanks for subbing
so i think this move defends upon
through
some kind of x-ray vision and this one's
a bit overworked now
i think it's important to get my queen
off the file
and if white has to take then i'm i'm
happy b4 might be coming
i really want to play this move but
does it work probably not
let's take it once and do this
okay so if white takes like all the
times then that file opens in the end
i'm defending the bishop threatening e3
that's a good move
go for this
okay now e3 is a
legal move
also take
stick with queen i have 26 seconds
e3 again
[Music]
no time to calculate
so the idea is to take on f2 if i get
the chance
okay
not looking so great for me though
my bad g5 let's go
twitch has built-in uptime now though
oh no my queen please take it
yes that was the only way that was the
only way
i had to i had to offer the queen trade
and then move my king here
and then wait for the free move let's go
let's go
yeah hicaro fell into that a few days
ago in in choker
it was a nice nice little resource
i was very similar too because my
opponent of course saw the first
trick where like the queen was just
hanging but ever
like so many people pre-move um
allowing king h8 okay let's let's
continue
let's play f bishop f4
otherwise i was just going to lose that
game like so badly
oh this is a fun line uh but the point
kind of knows what they're doing
i think it's this move
there's some some threat of taking and
attacking the bishop
hello youtube oh yeah yeah i i have to
make like a compilation of all those
all of those uh like frozen stalemate
traps there's so many
i have to go back in the vods
bishop d6 this looks fun
g4 is also a legal move
oh i think so much
so it's a question can i defend the pawn
sufficiently it's a queen wall
will come to a3
i don't want to allow knight c5 though
let's see
i could just go insane no let's
start with queen a3
i was thinking g4 at some point
oh knight f7 is coming
okay trying to complete development's
castle
allowing knight d3 king f1
it's a confusing position oh yeah i
think someone jameel
sharing the hacaro clip
hmm f4
the e4 but e4
i want to get the knight to uh to e4 to
defend the pawn
and also bishop b3
interesting
so knight g4 or knight d3 could be a
threat
if i play queen b4
[Music]
let's try it
another another game with a time deficit
position is probably slightly worse for
me
so the pawn is pinned
good move
and paul is attacked expecting bishop f7
don't know what to do here
oh i got i saw this threat too
i just was worried about yeah this idea
i'm gonna need another another random
miracle to save this
f5 positional i want to play g4
and probably some planet h4 g5
knight is is on the best square possible
oh
it's my favorite opening
let's go for this
um
good move
ah oh black out low on time
but yeah i really wasn't sure what to do
in uh
in this position because d4 was a threat
and this was a threat
i wanted to play king f2 but in d4 and
then rook c2 happens
so maybe i'm just worse
i just have to allow rook c2
okay interesting game
hey it's dawid
urbanski welcome back yeah it's been a
while
and good to see you back and it's the
news creator of opening tree
um and thank you purple platypus subbing
for two months thanks so much
um okay so
what's what's closer let's play e4 i'm
gonna mix it up
i played a lot of london's time for a
knight c3 sicilian grand prix attack
threatening this
[Music]
i don't mind this because the g file is
open
try and actually try and get rid of this
knight first
okay f5 is very thematic here
let's just do it
so i have two bishops i want to open up
the position
actually if g takes i might play f4 just
to first attack the knight
the e-file is now open too
and that pawn is pinned so i am
threatening to take twice
which opponent misses
yeah this bishop is so strong
probably this move
it's not going to be easy for for black
to defend i'm already threatening to
take
and then um and bishop h6 and there's no
defense
yeah that phone wants to move but it's
still pinned
it's just meet next move test yeah
oh thanks so much oh hari krishnan
i thought that was like a new person
cheering trying to to test it out
that was a nice game that was like a
quick grand prix
miniature did i miss work off six
i don't know oh my clocks strong player
um i'll place a ceiling in this game
trying to remember any sort of like
preparation
i vaguely remember d6 and knight f5 but
there's also like this and this
i think knight g6 there should be seven
f6
so i have the bishop here white has a
slightly annoying
bind on the position but i don't think
it's
too
too annoying it's going to be a fight
so i can play bishop before
some kind of bishop a6 move
it stares into empty space but maybe
someday it'll be relevant
i want to always be considering the pawn
breaks
okay now there's the idea of taking and
then taking on f3
let's take first
knight takes as possible
i mean taking on f3 actually looks
really tempting
let's just do it thanks for all the
content oh thank you for the bits
jamie's fraser 31 so this is
this is the only thing i calculated
queen e4 rook before
and the queen is tied down to this pawn
uh there's some idea of i guess of queen
of fate
even of uh of bishop c5
are probably not working though oh
there's also bishop g5
that's a nifty move
that's a really nice move because it
takes a fork a triple fork
quadruple fork quintuple fork and then
otherwise the queen
the queen has no safe square to still
defend the pawn
so i'm guaranteed to either fork or win
the queen
or both
f4 i just take
so i'm wondering if if rook takes f3
with sound
it still might be a fight though
queen c5 is a nice counter attack
i can take king g2 i take with check if
king here
oh white resigns if king hero is going
to play rook h4
i was just completely wrong that was
really nice
yeah minus 16. um
so i'm just curious is this approved hey
rook f3
it's a nice like kind of puzzle position
because initiative was just so strong
all right resume
okay so i have a streak 25 points
oh farouza's playing so i'm only about
halfway to frugia
a little less less than halfway
oh thanks for the fortnite bits or the
fork the fork knight
i heard fortnite let's play let's
suppose let's play e4
good luck
queen g6 i'll play this line
i just realized my opponent was working
back okay that's nice
i always play king b1
yeah it's going to be some like quiet
kind of carol con position
unless unless i play this
let's have some fun it's a gambit
probably not a sound gambit
ooh castles okay this will also be fun
or it'll just be positional it's going
to be positional
but maybe eventually tactical bishop c3
coming
have you tried creating puzzles
positions
with one key idea and no cooks
i never really got into that
um i'm sure i have
at some point
but it never really got into like
hardcore
composing let's play f4
uh knight d4 could be strong
let's just trade rooks
i'm in a little bit of trouble here
unless unless i can stir up something on
the queen side
my king is out of play
am i breaking i'm breaking through i
have one past pawn but that's enough
17 seconds that should also be enough
the bishop far away
and i can't stop the pawn
okay that was nice um
yeah that was like a double berserk game
got the five bezerking points
let's work again i'll play e4
play a tricky line
oh let's not pre-move windy six
wow is this some prep i haven't seen
this one before
so i have two bishops
b5
actually i think this is okay because
i'm trying e5 if takes here
okay we're not going into that
let's just take an e3
it doesn't feel like i'm up a pawn
though
black has a bit of comp oh and can win
back the pawn
i can move
keep up the good work man oh thanks so
much
i'll try this is a really difficult
position
in this move
my time situation too
a nice move
yeah rook d3 is the simplest approach
for black
my my queen side pawns are pretty
[Music]
useless
uh
yeah well played i liked i like the
position from the opening
but i played too slowly black yeah black
out a lot of compensation for
for the pawn down
my pieces came to life or my pieces
never got to come to life
i'm just too slow to develop berserking
was probably a mistake
so what happened to carlson did carlson
just uh oh
okay that's berserk the potential excel
dessert
playing the slime
it's a fun variation
oh oh my bad
uh mud
if i if i flag this game it's all
robot's fault
oh thanks for that
i'm trying to try and avoid the
condolence bits
in the future
okay this is playable
i have center but i have a rook
oh tricky tricky move it was a very
tricky move
it was like a backwards discovery
okay that was nice opponent just
plundered a rook that game
so i'm close to the top 100 which would
be nice
oh i think thanks bicycle for the
condolence bits
yeah it is um i should say this but
uh it is hard to play a tournament like
this
and be so involved uh
looking at the chat okay london time
and gm namiro from france
d5 so soon i can do this
oh this line
remember mvl playing this line wait this
is an nvl is it
it could be but probably not
rating's too low so i'm threatening this
that's definitely not mvl and we all
like how the game in from this position
at some point there's some like crazy
psych for black
i thought c5 was like the move you can
take
i'm still threatening to trap the knight
the knight's trapped this is the whole
point of 92 is to just leave the knight
awkward wow
12 move win over gm some uh
yeah it's a little bit of nice opening
prep opponent just didn't know
didn't know the line
is he online i don't know you guys can
tell me
i like i like when people berserk
what was bishop f4
huh
interesting
okay i'm just going to try and play
solidly positionally
acquainting this and maybe this
eventually
also take a knight f6 looks fine
yeah i want to keep my time advantage
interesting check
so i'm gonna allow queen h7
and then my king might go for a walk
but the the focus should be in the
center
yeah i could move
yeah my king's gonna definitely go for a
walk i'll land on f6
uh e4 could be really annoying
e4 then i take
e5
good move let's go for this
if i was threatening to win the queen oh
i'm allowing rick's team one
oh this is just losing
oh but i'm threatening rookie chad
actually oh
oh but e5 in the end
play this oh my opponent blunders
like some queen trap wow so white
doesn't take my queen
white didn't take my queen white has a
draw
oh but white also probably has a win oh
this is check though
so many plot twists
i'm alive how am i alive here
let's go somehow i won that like like i
was just dead
after rook c1 i guess my opponent didn't
realize the queen is still hanging
let's play a walrus okay walrus turned
into english
looks playable
27 idea 25.
good move
not the move i wanted to play but
to make do
maybe some c5 move
now this is playable now
good move
i can't solve f3 or f3 and h3
ah i wanted to play this there we go
it comes to d4
draw
no draw by d5
playing for a win
play this move b-pod is pinned
i think this wins
let's go wow i won that i broke through
it was like a mutual fortress but
somehow somehow the
the end game was winning i was very
risky
so two oh three four berserk wins in a
row wow
top 50 let's go
that was a very big risk so i was low on
time opponent just was offering
repetition
at some point i thought we were repeated
too but i guess not
oh thanks helsinki friend uh
that's so beautiful yeah at first i
thought that said chad is so beautiful
which is also maybe maybe a true
statement
okay so this is some kind of new trendy
london line
um the queen f3 and g4
i actually like the position h4
possibilities
i'm very much in shape to attack on the
king side
if c5 i have knight b5
let's push probably e4 coming
oh black pieces i see five coming this
is a beautiful position
more beautiful than the chat no offense
chat
i have this and this uh let's play this
yeah now this and this and then this
maybe
this first
night of faith i i do all the forking
really enjoying myself here
i was that was so beautiful that was a
great great opening like prep
i mean black kind of just didn't know
what to do probably starting with c6
smurray 1994 continuing the subgift
you got from double the ponds thanks so
much oh as beautiful as the chat thanks
for
their correction john so i'm top 30.
feels like a few games ago i was top 200
i'm still top of 200 oh i'm playing a
strong oh
oh i prepared for him i did very
specific preparation for him
but now i forgot everything he plays e5
right
oh he plays c5 okay i did some like
weird london prep
that was a while ago
play e4
so he's not because working okay so i
have to take
visual b2
and black's completely fine here but it
is tricky black's a little bit
underdeveloped
and there's this prospect of taking on
d4 and 82
some positional play
i played this very similar line against
eric hanson
in like an over the word blitz
tournament
d4 and d4 makes the most sense
i want to develop the bishop
yeah probably f3 bishop moves i have
knight f4
also knight g3 ideas
let's start with bishop f4 and queen d2
that's a good move queen b3
i have to be very careful playing queen
b3 i think it's playable
oh i lost a pawn
well i was up a pawn so when you when
you're up a pawn and you lose a pawn
that's just equal material it's not in a
bad position because i have this idea
can do i want to take maybe bishop c2
and bishop b4 let's take a knight c3
bishop e5
and the d5 comes
i feel like i'm getting outplayed
f6
so i can take with the bishop and hold
on to the pawn
but the knights are stronger than my
bishop which is kind of sad
but also kind of true i have this move
so if rookie 2 rook do you want the king
f1
otherwise i'll just bring my king in
start with this
[Music]
oh very tricky
that was a great move
so if i take
a five then bring my king in
doesn't quite work
i might just be losing here that was a
great move
let's go for this line
problem is the knight's going to come to
c6
i'm just losing
this move
or the kings coming to b5 i have to try
something
try this and attack from behind
so
that's not even stalemate okay well
played
yeah this this rook b6 idea is very
strong
um but he's like he's a good player he's
one of the the strongest blitz players
on the chest
all right life goes on let's play walrus
um c5 is the move here
yeah so this is a very dubious opening
but um i'm only down a pawn
could be worse okay g5 let's go
rook d a i'll probably go for c6
or i'll lose another pawn or i won't
okay
i'll play c6
that was a good move or was it
free pawn so i don't know if there's any
great discoveries
that's one discovery
i think i'm happy with trading
nights
let's put the queen on c6 and castle in
king g7
oh rookie rook t6
it's still a threat
queen f3
got a speed up
good move
[Music]
oh wait does that work oh that does work
well played
not enough time okay lesson
don't play the walrus against strong
players
still top 50. lost two in a row
uh over an hour left
any points so i have 51 points
yeah that was a nice some nice streak
but
oh oh this is a wait what game was that
oh that came i was black okay this game
unwind
play one of these
i enjoy these uh these structures threat
was b5
i'll start with this
now the idea is this
and then i'd use like rook before i'm
just going after the pawn
i think i'm just winning this pawn
i'm black going for counter play oh but
i can take and attack the knight
and then this pawn is hanging too
pretty sure it's solid
black resigned yeah it was just dominant
completely dominant opening
um i basically got to play all the the
typical moves in that line too
like knight a5 the rook lift to b4
i'm playing creep 30.
okay
so queen's gambit declined
um let's play 97
i should know what i'm doing in this
line
i have a vague idea just getting my my
typical
my typical setup to take with pawn
c7 in some cases is under under pressure
i'll maneuver the knight
yeah i've had some nice games oh free
pawn free pawn
i was very generous
had some nice like opening preparation
this tournament
oh if rook a1 i played bishop b2 i win
material okay so let's
um let's try and keep playing quickly
this bishop b4 there's no pawn on e3 to
kick me away but there is a knight
i guess we can trade
and 94.
so i'm playing kind of a sort of
stonewall
attack type thing
uh the main idea is f4 and just trying
to open the e-file
because white has a lot of things on the
on the queen side so i want to focus on
the king side
oh that's attacking this i have b5 here
i think b5 is solid and
yeah actually b5 is nice because it
fixes the pawn on on
b4 it restricts the bishop restricts the
knight
this is still defended
rook b3 is confusing i should play king
h8
just getting off the alignment
f4 should be coming soon
wait i can just take in bishop d5
it's a clearance tactic but also just
attacking a knight
[Music]
yeah whatever that means
looks nice i mean white can take in when
a6
um oh but then rook ate an end
oh but then b5 hangs i don't know
okay not going for it so let's let's
take here
white's trying to fight
i'll shift over to that file because f2
is probably the main target
some idea of taking in queen g3 takes
queen g3
and quite slightly to take with queen i
guess
hmm let's just be simple oh rick's e6 is
a threat
yeah let's play this and then be simple
just trade queens keep the time
advantage
i don't really want to take i could play
rook f6
preventing future rook c6 now
probably i should take
and take
still takes a bit of technique
but i want to have some fun on the king
side i see five coming
i can still have fun rookie 2
turning rook here and threading this
good move
maybe just a5
that wasn't a good move uh i have to
have to do this i'll win i'll win d4
thankfully
i'll do this first and c6
it's still a winning ending not sure how
great my technique was but
let's get some g5 g5 action
there we go
didn't want to steal me there
okay i was really close opponent really
fought
after blending upon and losing the
exchange
um i try and try to keep my composure
a little bit more green tea
i made a lot of tea before this let's
turn
okay what was the previous game
huh oh i played the walrus let's not
play the walrus
let's play whatever this is
knight c3 interesting i think i can just
take
i'm being greedy here
being very greedy
oh e4
um
i have rook t8
i should not have been greedy i have b5
okay i'm continuing to be greedy i want
to play e5
maybe gifa
g5 is not great i'll play g6 eventually
maybe it's paying off oh i didn't see
that move
okay unintended king development
wait a minute bishop d5 was a good move
if i take
actually maybe complete this
i should win one of the bishops
i'm gonna lose back some pawns down a
lot of time
material's just equal wow i'm down a lot
of time
no no no no no i want to play with d8
let's try and fight
ah g5 mates oh i mouse slipped
that was a cool it was a cool position
somehow i survived that
ah i think that was my first mouse at
this this tournament
gm caching okay
i can't berserk opponents almost 200
points higher rated
than me
thanks for subbing pass pawn quadruple
nine center fork trick
against a gm
so knight b4 is uh is larry kaufman's
recommendation
in his book a kaufman rapper tour
i think it addresses this line did i go
wrong
no i remember studying this this is
supposed to be good for black
uh but why
some knight c2 move still not fed and
master
keep trying keep trying oh it's feather
mask oh
oh yeah there's a twitch streamer with a
similar username
i can take here but thanks for subbing
for five months
oh i should have seen that coming
i have to have to defend
so if rook c1 i take and knight covers
e1
a messy position i mean like might play
rookie one anyway
what oh we're just trading
hopefully please let's just let it be a
trade
if rookie one we i take and then king of
seven i'm still alive
oh the queen wasn't sure about that line
okay let's start with queenie seven i
guess
oh i have this move
[Music]
d7
i'm scared of rookie one but okay it's
not too scary
queen g8 it's a threat so probably king
f8
rook d1 is coming unfortunately
where's my play
my knight's gonna get stuck which is a
big problem
unless i can get in bishop f5 maybe this
move
bishop five feels so wrong because i'm
walking into
the pin on the c file
oh why am i just take that's also
interesting
okay let's just sack a rook oh no my
rook
idea d oh d2 doesn't work though
oh so i just lost a rook
i don't know why i thought d2 worked
ah do i have anything here
i have um maybe this no
let's try this move threatening d2
you see five i'm down two exchanges
and down a ton of time but it's
interesting still
king f6 no checks
and g4 okay
start with d2
oh that was defended well played
oh there goes my queen
okay
as a tricky position not easy to play in
blitz
after the terminal i'll have to go back
and find the improvement
that's a cool line
okay london time bread and butter i'm
gonna go for this idea
whoa it's awesome q8 it should be good
for black but
why question of the day yeah
need to ask the engine
but yeah um at least when i play that
line
it's based off the recommendation in
the kauffman wrapper tour for black um
which is a great it's great opening
wrapper tour book probably aimed for
players like 2000 plus
offers a lot of nice ideas
this is a nice line
this move
i'm going to win this pawn
probably should take the knight
yeah so the queen and knight develop a
tempo and then i'll just castle
probably just plant a rook here but
there is knight c4
that looks okay rookie 7 idea
but i probably don't want to play rookie
7.
or do i
yeah i'm gonna play it safe
oh
what good move
i should have not gone for this oh i
should have definitely not gone for that
oh wow i just i've completely collapsed
well played this is a blind spot
i'm just losing here anyway ah
i was really unfortunate i was a great
position too
yeah i wonder maybe i should have gone
for the two rooks versus the queen
yeah thanks for the oopsy dupesy sub
master disaster
that was that was a real disaster
that was an international master
disaster
all right playing ninja
let's play this move
qgd time
this is my pet line thanks for subbing
berlin
without the e and many rs oh like berlin
like it's cold
h4 what does h where so i don't want to
play h6
i think i should just take b5 c5
fs
oh to num the oofs yeah
oof is like a synonym for pain right
okay yeah when the opponent plays on the
flank it's usually
good to focus in the center on a4
i can i can play bishop b7 we trade
also play c4
a4 is interesting
i'll play c4 just questioning the bishop
and then
bishop e7
i'm not so sure about the slide
so i want to play b4 before
knight b1 i lose a pawn
i feel like i'm losing a pawn in every
line which is really annoying
let's go for this it seems like some
compensation
oh it doesn't even take it i spent all
my time calculating takes
okay so at least we have a line white's
committed to each point castle
which should be beneficial for me
somehow
so i'll probably play h6 when the time
is right
start with rook d8
h6 should come very soon
interesting
um so i have this queen c6 idea in the
end
maybe i can get away with this
i would take with bishop and h4 will be
attacked
if bishop f4
okay let's go into this line
oh bishop f3
i have queen a6 too
let's try this
it should be about equal but anything
can happen
not sure how useful this bishop is
queening one
was unexpected
i always have rook d8 so rook c it's not
mate
bishop covers the queen converse d8
oh i didn't see that though
okay so four on three
[Music]
not good
very little hope here
yeah well played ah d5 was very nifty
i just didn't see this man
it's tactical sharpness so i had to
like just retreat the bishop
well played
whoa that's that's four losses in a row
let's try and recover
let's play along all right let's play um
a non-london
sicilian time g space i'm trying
i'm trying play uh i had this line
earlier against chicago
yeah basically had the same position
after knight f6
g6 interesting
i guess g6 is playable
just castle
thanks for subbing rmk swimming at tier
one
thanks for that
ah d5 is gonna come
or not okay d5 still comes
now this is still very playable
yeah the bishop is actually a little bit
awkward on d4
um because they'll have knight e2 i also
have this move
black can play f6
not sure if it works i'll play queen f3
first
probably prepare this i really want to
make e5 work
just f6 is
is good enough for black i have f5 too
and also just take i'm just gonna play
very simple just take
take until basically there's a pawn that
lands here
it should be equal
and the watchmen subbing for three
months thanks so much
yeah so we trade everything um
black might be slightly better
just more space on the queen side
and b5 might come
f5 is a good positional move
i don't think i want to trade rooks
as this pawn is fixed on the dark square
i want to trade bishops
i also want to play this move
i'm probably just going to play the
waiting game for a little bit
if ever b5 i take and play broke a1
interesting
so that gives me the d4 square i can
taste
it there is yeah there's
gm hari krishnan
taking this move i think the a file is
more
more venomous rook a6 is hard to stop
there's lots of juicy targets
almost went upon here should you throw
in the check
first
and then i think i'm just winging the
pawn
okay let's take first
turning bishop c5 defining the pawn now
pawn can't really be defended
oh but my pawn can't be defended either
threatening bishop c5 again
let's just trade bishops
oh it's tricky
this is not easy
going for a dirty flag
yes
okay that was a really it was a really
dirty finish napoleon really survived
got counter play on the king's side but
uh
yeah i got got the flag hey i'm about to
break 2500 maybe
maybe i i was probably above 2 500
before those four losses
let's play london
40 minutes left this is a long long
tournament
london time oh knight h5
oh i should know this opening open
knight h5 in this position
[Music]
without taking let's play this
this is a move cheers cheers
cheers is usually signifying bits but
here it signifies a sub
thanks westy's good so i'm trying on the
knights
i have some vague memory of like some
crazy knight c4 move
where it turns queen g8 mate
i don't know in what position though
i think i'll just play rook b1
simple and solid
i need some f4 idea
it was like 26.50 i think my bullet
rating is around 26.50
i reached 20 2800 and then dropped
but this is blitz chess
i have f4
wow so this pawn's attacked
which means i'll have to do something
queen f3
bishop e2 in castle oh bishop c5
wow
i'm wondering if i can just take on c4
probably not good
this is not the move i want to play
that's a really sad move
i mean black also weakened uh his own
king's side
i have queen h5 here
i want to do some combination i think
i'll start with queen h5 and go for b4
just pre-move b4
if it takes probably take with a rook
chase the queen away from the the
battery
what
i don't think black meant to do that
um it's still kind of complicated i have
this move
i think this just wins
let's throw in a check and then all in
the pawn
threading maiden one
the king's going to run
we can trade queens
yeah let's trade queens up a rook
knight's going to come to d3 look like
he need to rook off
on them
oh that's slightly scary
black house comp and i'm so low on time
maybe i shouldn't have traded queens
it was monster night threatening rook h7
all right play definitely revolves
around the queen side
right h6 just king oh this one's a thing
there we go okay it took a little bit of
work
so i think a reasonable goal is it's
like top 50 probably
um but also i just want to finish by
playing like decent quality chess
it's really hard after three hours of
blitz
or like after two hours of blitz to
still be sharp
i have a really bad score against this
player
just play my my standard stuff
yeah it's hard to stay informed after
like so much blitz
okay we have this line oh yeah i had
this line another day
um
i think the yeah with against knight f3
the idea is just 97 queen c7
slowing down b4 now queen c7
i need to to study this line a bit more
thoroughly
some knight b6 idea
eventually knight c4 oh i did i blunder
or are we just we're just trading we're
just trading
at b3 i can take it
that may have been a positional blunder
on my part
it's not the end of the world
start with rook c and then they'll
eventually go for a4
some knight d2 move
play 98 idea 96.
maybe f6 coming too
now this shouldn't be so bad i've heard
from a lot of coaches to never resign
but when does that become rude
always depends on the situation
and if you're playing like a world
championship match and you're down a
queen from
no comp and maybe you can resign
that knight t2 doesn't quite work f6
knight d6 you have knight d2 i can take
and then b5 is loose
b6 here
maybe bishop f5
with the goal is 94. i have to watch out
for knight b4 though
okay
we can trade everything
so i can choo i i have the choice like
which end game to get
i might want the knight vs bishop it's
probably equal
yeah let's go for this
i'll bring the knight back to c4
oh did i blunder
i think i blundered
i'm allowing king b4 here here
i just wandered the white king is too
close
that's so sad
so
do
yeah that was a really bad like
miscalculation
wait what's going on here
is f3 a mistake a three was a mistake oh
no it wasn't a mistake
ah yeah
this is like a big rule about that game
like if you're gonna allow some trade
you have to make sure the kingpin ending
isn't lost
um yeah i should have just brought my
king in first
but my yeah my time management also
wasn't so great there
okay life goes on let's play e4
i haven't had a nakmansen i still won't
have enochmanson
play some quiet acquired approach
i'm allowing a 94.
have to watch out for the the e pawn
bishop f4 here this is like the ideal
development
bishop d3
it's going to be a fight so if e5
i guess that gives away the d5 square i
can't play d5 either
ah c5 is a good move
and just go into like some i guess some
sicilian position
queen d2 will come with tempo
be nice if i could get a pawn to c4
somarazzi bind structure
interesting
e5 is a bit weak
i really have to watch my time
this probably isn't so bad
bishop can be planted
like a seed on d4
and some 92
and 82 covers these things
g5 might happen or not
yeah just trying to be solid that's a
good sign
light wants to be on f3
a pawn's defended could be a long grind
defend the pawn
rook e2 defending
okay so i want to prepare g4 that's the
main the main breakthrough
some kind of queen d2 and then g4
because this pawn probably has to take
and then f5 can come
v2 square is undercover or under control
and the pawn storm is real
these pieces not doing too much
to defend the king
i hung upon okay let's go for this
oh f6 doesn't quite work
knight f3 f6 says
takes because of the pin
okay let's play this move attacking the
bishop
free bishop
i made a similar mistake earlier in the
tournament
this is still not over
oh i hung a knight what i hung a knight
okay let's queen here
oh no my position
ah
good move
there goes my position ah so i've i've
hung i've i want the bishop i don't know
maybe it was a sacrifice
i have to i forgot my knight was hanging
i had to play rook team one i guess that
was a nice
i was feeling good that game like nice
build up and it just
all collapsed in time pressure
okay still top hundred
oh thanks diamond cutter for the shout
outs
appreciate that
i think squishy i tried
today i try
let's play oh
watch time
i actually prepared this opening for
like a serious over the board game
on this g4 move but my opponent uh
who i prepared for didn't go into it
this looks really pleasant though
is everything i can ask for for a
structure like this
i guess e5 is a little bit weak
bring the queen to g3 to defend and to
attack
[Music]
thanks for subbing the answer is 42.
welcome back
yeah so the whole idea of getting the
pond h6 is to weaken the
the dark squares because i have the only
dark spread bishop on the board
yeah black is ready as a sack
oh good move i have to play this to
cover c2
not so pretty
i don't want to take the rook
rick d2
made some e4 move at the right moment
my bishop is just stuck
play this move
i have to go for dirtiness triple pawns
let's go
three times triple pawns are three times
as good as single pawns
play this move it's like a nice big
beautiful wall
keeping my king safe
quadruple pawns quadruple pawns for a
very brief moment
in time
yes quadruple homes hey it's connect
four
look at this look at this
yeah quadruple pawns are four times as
good
that was so nice i mean i i ran out of
plans
and opponent was very resourceful but
don't mess
don't mess with quadruple pawns
[Music]
i mean that that game might go on
youtube i don't think i've had quadruple
pawns on stream
i have it once off stream imrozen
connect four bits
yeah connect four
that was nice the pawns actually kept
the king really safe
yeah very youtube worthy
caller pm gifting a sub to guron zarich
thanks so much uh
let's play let's play e4 hey jay the
tiger
thanks for the one thousand bits elite
connect four yeah
play this line oh let's have some fun
take on b2 take it take it
i wanted to play the four queens line
and possibly the six queens line
but here we just have we have a quiet
position
nothing too too crazy
three oh that's the number of love
thanks i'm blobbish
or abolish wait what to play here
oh let's try i'm threatening to get
triple pawns again
okay now i'll just have
what we call hanging pawns
but knight before because i'm
threatening c5
i think it was copa blanca who who
introduced this idea
like when you have hanging pawns you you
play c5 to
make the sweetness
attacking this
basically just going for the bishop hair
calculating d5 also is looking at bishop
h7 doesn't quite work
so i'll just take if rook takes i have
this and this
if pawn takes and probably still this
i kind of just lost a pawn oh yeah
oh babylonian oh
similar to mesopotamia
i just lost a pawn i should probably
keep everything on the board
exactly i'm gonna lose another pawn
but more pawns you lose the more open
files you gain
and more diagonals you gain too
i don't know how great this is if i take
bishop takes
actually yeah yeah so if b6 looks solid
but it just loses to this
if this and this and the rook is always
tied down
uh from d8
queen e7 of this move
did i just miss a win with vertical
connect four
yeah you did oh brian oh you missed it
you can always watch the clip someone
better have clipped that
it'll be on the vod it'll be on youtube
eventually
okay let's go for the the pin and win
i'm actually i am threatening to take
immediately because uh
queen and rook are both overworked the
pawn is also weak
oh so if rook oh wait what
oh that was a good move you can take
oh this is confusing
i might just want to play the end game
down the pawn
but that's so fun
ah let's do it not thrilled about this
knight will have to to get to d8
oh i'm maybe threatening this
there's some comp here actually
okay point it miss rook checking rip d2
all comes down to time i have to play
the waiting game
c
congrats eric on reaching 100k youtube
subscribers oh thanks so much i
appreciate that
ah
no
ah that was just a drawn ending
i i froze at the wrong moment
actually i i simplified into just a bad
end game a losing end game
[Music]
too bad almo almost got the dirty flag
but not quite
thank you sang sanga nakam i appreciate
the sub
for seven months
so hovering around 2500
um no when the sub alert came i had
already committed myself to that line
so what to do
caller pm continuing the sub gifts you
got from joe king thanks for that
um
play uh let's play one of these
ooh halloween time halloween time
reverse halloween
interesting wait a minute
this is like center fork i think queen
g5 is a decent move
queen g5
this is like the center fork trick
variation
i guess h3 was useful
and play um
bishop a6 first very very nice move
d3 hits my queen
93 expected
or oh castling's a good move too
so if takes and i do this and the knight
and rook are hanging
oh my god out of the pin
but maybe can i take
it's risky
i don't see anything concretely wrong
with it
knight g4 maybe queen d5
it's a weird game so far
i can take and then
bishop b7 eventually c5 bishop d6
maybe no i can't play rook h6
okay
oh i'm allowing bishop f4 or that
but i have this okay i want you to play
bishop f4
okay this is survivable maybe losing
this pawn
can't play c5 thanks for the bits
anonymous cheer with 100 bits well
hacker 88
thanks for subbing
okay less than 10 minutes left in the
tournament
let's go for g5 to go for something
maybe eventually f4
it feels wrong putting my king on a dark
square with this bishop
but i mean the pin was
too painful white's calculating oh
that's a good move to play this
oh the knight is now trapped or at least
stuck
idea of g4 g3
this bishop is actually a very good
piece now
f4 probably
threatening this
ah went wrong i lost this pawn beloved
g5 pawn
question is how bad is it
sacking another pawn just for this move
oh thanks anonymous appreciate that
the night is still stuck
wow what is this position
i'm threatening this actually it's a
sneaky threat
i mean white has b4 knight b3 but then i
win some pawns
there we go
oh that was bad move that was a really
bad move
this is very dangerous
i'm losing no
there goes my king ah
wow position was so nice jay the tiger
the subgis
thanks jay some moral
so some sympathy sub or some sympathy
sub yes
f3 was a good move i should have played
this so the pawns got way too strong
thanks jay gifting to
chris manchester casey mr mystery ones
instruction manual subway platform mind
lord blizza nipsey 1999
jan wiglaf fart underscore face
underscore underscore
log jimmy danmar 777 and luca
numbers okay let's do zerk and let's try
and finish strong
okay four nights
copycat variation
bishop g4 so i haven't committed to
casting which means i want to play g5
like g5 g4
let's get a pawn cube or a pawn square
yeah pawn square let's go
maybe this move
hey 1k subs thanks people
oh maybe the thing didn't update but i
appreciate it
it's castle
um let's take
this is very close to winning and queen
h4 will come
okay cheat
hmm
wow
it's not winning oh oh
oh queen takes with check i was thinking
rook g2 just wins
but our life goes on let's play this
move
are we going to see quadruple pawns
again we might
twice in the same tournament thanks so
much
quadruple pawns let's go
pretty sure that took us to 1k subs
thanks jay
oh thanks jay i appreciate that yeah jay
the tiger
ultimate tiger
ah what to do maybe let's move
going after this pawn
and no quadruple pawns this game that's
sad
we're one move away
draw
no no
ah oh
[Music]
that can't be the last game that can't
be the last game for me
and rook g3 was a bad pre-move
that was a really bad pre-move okay
final game
we're going to end and try and end on a
happy note
we can take that yeah let's play this
move attack the pawn
are you planning a viewer swiss
tournament any time soon
oh didn't you ask me that last time and
i said remind me later
yeah it'll it'll happen especially if
you keep asking that
f3 greedy move but
i'm up a pawn
i'm still up a pawn
hmm
so knight wants to get to e6 so my plan
is this this and this
i don't care about this battery rookie 4
queen d3
oh i'm losing a pawn though if you could
remove a single piece in chess which one
would you remove along with air
coordinates
not sure what to do here oh i'm up a
pond though so i'm
it's gonna be equal material hopefully
okay there we go threatening the rook
i didn't do too much
getting outplayed
ah sad finish but that's life
um i like my position
but then yeah around here like it wasn't
clear what to do
thanks each rot
sobbing for two months um
i mean the night looks so pretty but
this pond was weak
and oh i should have taken here oh
yeah got a little bit burnt out
or just played b3 yeah b3 c4 is a plan
i was thinking black was going to take
here
i'm actually curious
yeah this is just just good for white
so back to trim it hey alireza
so carlson does carlson play anything
chat was saying something
oh he only played oh wow so he had 100
win rates
out of five games and he just left
so alireza wow berserk's like every game
well not even close to
you should make elite goo a motel ah
i made a let's go emote because if i add
more ease
then it would have to be smaller
but um i'll consider thanks j for the
bits
and all the gifted subs um
let's see where was i
so i had some interesting games slightly
disappointing finish
i mean the favorite game had to be the
quadruple pawns game
which i forget which one it was
which one was it
oh wait
oh this one yeah this one
just very brief quadruple pawns
i'm very thumbnail-worthy